well good evening and welcome glad that
you're here and it's wonderful to see a
big crowd like this our gathering this
evening is is sponsored by the
department's of English and history here
at Hope College and we have the support
of the Office of the provost and the
Dean of Arts and Humanities and we're
grateful for their support my name is
David Closter I'm the chair of the
English department and I'm pleased to
welcome you and to introduce this
evening speaker annalisa Cox grew up
just a bit south of here out in the
country and she was home-schooled which
means she had the best teachers and her
book is dedicated to those teachers for
showing her the way her book is full of
the kinds of local color observations
that a michigan girl could make of
someone with time on her hands to wander
through the woods she notices the
peculiar way that a locust tree blossoms
in a michigan forest in the spring and
she notices in the book the way that the
sumac and the sassafras turned colors in
the fall and she pays special attention
to the unpredictable winter weather in
michigan that can wreak havoc with the
winter wheat crop and all of those sorts
of things show up in her book Anna Lisa
Cox was a student here at Hope College
she was a history major she graduated in
1994 and in her senior history seminar
with Professor bill Cohen she had the
opportunity to do a research project on
local history and she started
researching the town of covert and and
her project started while she was still
a student here at ed lake at at Hope
College covert is about 35 miles south
of here it's along the Lake Michigan
shore a bit inland from the shore and
that undergraduate research project has
blossomed into the book that we're here
to learn about tonight
annalisa has a master's degree in social
anthropology from the University of
Cambridge England and she holds the PhD
in American history from the University
of Illinois she's currently a scholar in
residence at the Newberry Library in
Chicago
in her book a stronger kinship anna-lysa
cox writes many scholars feel that the
most interesting histories happen during
those moments of violence that reshape
institutions but anna-lysa is not
exactly that kind of historian she's one
with an era tuned to quieter moments for
example the Long Walk that a former
slave makes from North Carolina to
Michigan in the 1860s or to the moment
of neighborliness expressed by an
individual when a newcomer shows up in
town or the significance of the day when
an African American merchant makes a
loan to a white customer or the day an
outsider gets elected as highway
commissioner or the day the ladies of
covert have a Strawberry Festival
fundraiser to support the community band
or she pays attention to the long term
meaning of friendships formed in a young
people society at a local church in her
book a stronger kinship weaves those
kinds of quiet moments together into a
rich and compelling narrative of life in
a small Midwestern town from the end of
the Civil War into the 20th century the
kind of town that any of our cities or
villages could have become but the kind
that only little covert michigan
actually became dr. cox sets the events
of covert into the context of race
relationships in the united states the
time from reconstruction until the 20th
century and in that history of covert
she's uncovered a story that delights
and challenges and inspires us to think
about and to think newly about what's
normal in race relations in our
institutions and in our towns and in our
cities so please welcome Anna Lisa Cox
[Applause]
thank you truly a joy to be here today
it feels a lot like coming home I'm
going to get started pretty quickly here
just so you know you have heads up I'll
be talking for about 40 minutes and I'm
going to leave plenty of time for
questions and answers and again I would
ask if I point to you that you wait just
a couple minutes for that mic to come
out over your head so that we can
actually hear what your question is I'm
gonna start off with a quote by Richard
Wright which is where I drew the title
for my book a stronger kinship he wrote
a wonderful book in the late 1930s
called 12 million black voices and he is
really talking about what he hopes
America could be like given everything
that African Americans and people of
European descent have shared in this
country the differences between black
folk and white folk are not blood or
color
and the ties that bind us are deeper
than those that separate us the common
road of hope
which we all have traveled has brought
us into a stronger kinship than any
words laws or legal claims and in
unusual covert Michigan they were able
to do so I'm going to start off with
basically the beginning this is the
chapters called the journey
it covers 1862 1866 and basically it
shows how this small extremely rough
frontier community of very young people
mainly from the east coast over half of
the population was under the age of 20
managed to meld themselves into
community with about 25 African
Americans who arrived from all over the
nation in the same year about 1866 now
many of those African Americans who
arrived were civil war veterans
and they'd actually seen action during
the Civil War they were highly
politicized by this experience but they
also came with a certain amount of
courage and grace because they came from
mainly African American communities
and they were taking their courage in
their hands and they were moving to the
north western frontier in southwestern
Michigan in to an area that though it
had few people living there all of them
were white so we will start there the
journey she must have been so tired of
walking
Elizabeth Connor was moving and moving
in the Midwest in 1866 meant walking
walking for days through wilderness
through strangers the wilderness pressed
so close that even horses had trouble
passing through the roots that ripped
and branches that scratched Elizabeth
almost certainly walked with a group of
roughly 20 although only ten of them
were adults old experiences old wounds
had talked these travelers that there
was strength in numbers and in arms
Elizabeth's husband and her
brothers-in-law all had weapons
she knew had killed many of what a
southern white man not long ago so she
walked with the dear Nancy and Abigail
and they walked alongside husbands
strangers stared at those dark warriors
and their wives must have had the same
urge the man had walked together for
years over hundreds of miles walked
through mud above their knees walked
through the wrecked bodies of their dead
comrades walked straight into gunfire
when everything in them was telling them
to run away now they walked together
with their unfamiliar children their
long imagined wives now reel into a
dreamed future they plan to make true a
future of fairness and prosperity like
many pioneers in America's past they had
left a stable and sure place to find a
more successful life that place was the
only home Elizabeth had ever known Mount
Pleasant Cass County Michigan Cass
County had given shelter to a group of
Quakers in the 1830s who then made it
home to any blacks who wanted to come
and they came by the hundreds some were
escaping slaves rebelling against the
idea that they were owned by anyone
others were long free but sought the
freedom the south would no longer offer
them in Cass County they
able to attend schools farm their own
land and raise their families this was
more than unusual it was feared in the
antebellum Midwest although some white
settlers are willing to use
african-american slave labor and there
were slaves in the Midwest before the
Civil War most were averse to the idea
of african-americans living near them
especially if they were free
this attitude extended deep into the new
northern territories as a legislative
committee in Ohio made clear in 1832
free blacks were considered more of a
threat than slaves for they were seen as
and I'm quoting a corrupting influence
and quote and more important they
infringed upon white employment
opportunities Elizabeth's father Henry
Shepard had been among the hundreds who
sought shelter in Cass County before the
war and who had managed to escape census
takers and slave catchers to make a home
south of Canada a home in a nation that
was rightly his until he turned 21 Henry
Shepard had been owned by someone Henry
promised himself that on his 21st
birthday he would liberate himself and
he did walking north as best he could
but North was the direction the winter
came from howling in hard and the most
freedom he found was a swamp where he
could hide Henry's feet slowly froze and
rotted from the wet ground but that pain
was not as terrible as the loss of
liberty and he must have gone down
running still trying to move even after
the dogs found him and the white men
recaptured him the man who thought of
himself as Henry's owner may have taken
one look at Henry's destroyed feet and
felt sure that here was a safe slave one
who would literally never run again but
as soon as he deemed himself recovered
Henry made another bid for freedom this
time he was successful and he kept
walking north on those rotten feet until
he had walked all the way to Canada
maybe Canada ended up being too cold for
a man who had been brought low by a
winter Michigan wasn't easy but it was
easier
and more settled and it gave Henry a
place to become a hero although he
managed to keep the fact secret from
most who knew him for many years he was
a conductor on the Underground Railroad
bringing escaping slaves from Cass
County to the next station in
Schoolcraft and sometime beyond he must
have been determined that others would
not suffer as he had to find the way to
freedom
he married had a family had his daughter
Elizabeth and then the war came what
could possess an old man a man with
family and a home a man with freedom to
walk back into the land that had
enslaved him all that it happened to him
in those first 21 years of his life must
have risen up in him must have taken him
to that enlistment station and then
Henry walked again walked all the way
back to the south with a gun in his hand
and almost all the black men of Cass
County went with him now some have
argued that Midwestern racism was
actually worse than the racism of the
south as an editor of an Iowa paper
wrote in 1862 it has long been manifest
that there was a far greater prejudice
existing against association with the
Negro at the North than at the south and
quote obviously this is an old argument
yet the Midwest was also a beacon of
hope for both blacks and whites intent
on settling and creating a new way of
being together these sentiments may not
have been popular but they were strong
enough to create open warfare before the
Civil War and strong enough to put
through some of the earliest civil
rights laws passed in this country Henry
Shepard did not walk on injured feet to
settle in Michigan because it was worse
than being enslaved he probably would
have agreed with historian and
sociologist Charles Payne who wrote and
I quote the southern racial system in
fact allowed for a great deal of
personal contact across racial lines
perhaps more so than in other parts of
the country it just had to be contact on
terms defined by white people now just
because white Republican men in covert
had fought for the United States was no
guarantee that they would feel warmly
towards the blacks who chose to settle
in their community
indeed in 1862 Union soldiers from
Indiana kept a group of African
Americans from crossing the Ohio River
into Indiana and freedom by aiming guns
at the fugitives they made it clear
through their actions and the shouted
epithets that their regiment was not
fighting to make their state a haven for
blacks this could easily have been the
Welcome received by Elizabeth Connor and
her family resulting in black and white
Union veterans facing each other in fear
and anger instead there was the welcome
the surprise of welcome the Welcome was
doubly surprising because the Connors in
the group were not the only people of
African descent arriving in covert there
were also the Pampas Indiana natives
Washington and Napoleon Pompey were
young and single these brothers were the
advance scouts the adventurers their
names were Noble and grand their parents
pride in their babies shouted loud and
clear while they were lighter than the
Connors and Tyler's racism had not dealt
lightly with these young men with dark
curling hair and gray eyes or with their
families their father Dawson and his
brother fielding do not show up in
federal census records until 1850 and by
then they were fully grown men with
families their descendants today hold
many histories of Dawson and Fielding
all agreed that the two were both sons
of the same slave woman some say that
she was so beloved by her master that
when she bore Dawson her master's wife
became jealous and he had to give the
enslaved woman to his brother who also
became enamored of her and soon she
became pregnant with fielding others say
that it was just one master who loved
his mistress so much that he freed her
and her sons to live in Ohio where the
two boys became skilled horseman
training and writing resources the most
secret at the time
of all the versions is connected to
those horses I'm still grateful to the
families for entrusting me with this
amazing story in this version told by
one of Washington Papi's granddaughter's
either Dawson or fielding was entrusted
by a master with transporting gold and
racehorses to a race in a non slave
state once in the Free State the daring
Pompey took the money and the horses and
ran if indeed Dawson and fielding had
escaped slavery in order to live free
and successful lives in the Midwest they
had every reason to want to guard the
details of their past in order to
protect their present and their future
this was not at all unusual among people
who made the dangerous choice of freedom
Elizabeth Connors father Henry Shepard
did not allow his story of escape to
become public until after his death even
though he lived for decades after
slavery was abolished as for Dawson's
sons Washington and Napoleon the miracle
was their survival although they could
have passed for white
they wore Africa into battle joining the
8th chord a freak a philadelphia-based
black regiment a band of soldiers they
would see its men slaughtered at a
horrific rate the brothers fought side
by side protecting each other two the
long months of terror and death when
they tried to return home they were
reminded that it was not only the
Confederates that hated them black
soldiers would lived for years in
Indiana before going off to fight were
now prohibited from returning home to
their families because they had not
followed to the letter of the law
Indiana's harsh and ever-changing Black
Codes
even if they had shed their blood for
their country they had not paid their
black code bond to Indiana and Indiana
would not let them in Washington and
Napoleon had grown up in a state that
denied its black residents so much and
they were not going to be denied anymore
they went almost straight from
Brownsville Texas where they had been
discharged to Michigan they arrived in
1866 at the same time as the Connors the
Tyler's and
Seaton's meanwhile the Condors in the
group from Cass County all settled on
the land that William and Heinrich had
bought at the northeast edge of covert
Township almost immediately William's
father William bright Connor bought 40
acres adjoining his son's land and it is
obvious he picked the land for a very
specific reason it had a school on it I
had a big fight with my editor over this
one I kind of wanted to call this
chapter 40 acres in a school but he
wouldn't let me something a hint at his
motivation can be seen in the actions of
the african-american John Watson in
Illinois in 1875 now this is almost 10
years later
Watson leased land that had a local
public school on it that at the time was
teaching only white students with lease
in hand he went to the school board
asking for the keys to the school with
the intent of opening its doors to all
the children who lived in the region the
school board refused the black man
warned he'd use force and head of the
school board pulled out a shotgun and
threatened to shoot the integrationist
Watson promptly sought a warrant against
the man the case dragged on for a number
of years and ultimately came to an
unsatisfactory conclusion for Watson
integrated education was not just
frowned upon by the state of Michigan in
1866 it was illegal and had been for
more than 25 years so when Williams
father William bright Connor bought that
land with the school and he was not just
challenging the local community while
culvert may have been on the frontier
its schools were already part of the
state bureaucracy there was a school
board whose superintendent sent detailed
yearly reports to the State Capitol
covert took the education of his
children so seriously that it had hired
teachers before preachers and built
schools before it even had a meeting
hall for local elections these were not
red brick structures most were not even
white clapboard they were ruff shelters
doubling in some cases as barns despite
the rough conditions the covert school
board still managed to get its reports
in to Lansing often chatty and tone
describe the condition of the buildings
the health of the students and even the
behavior of the students as one
superintendent wrote in 1864 and I quote
the schools have good order morals and
behavior good for the backwoods and a
new Township and now a group of blacks
have settled in the township on land
that had one of the townships precious
schools on it rather inelegant an
integrated education was a highly
contested issue in the 19th century
Midwest most White's across the region
were violently opposed to such racial
mixing indeed many Midwestern whites
were opposed to blacks getting an
education in any form one teacher Sara
Curtis who was not even attempting to
teach in an integrated school just to
lead a class of all african-american
children in Galatian County Illinois
just after the Civil War wrote that
after months of being ostracized by
local White's for her position she gave
up and I'm quoting in utter disgust at
her neighbors actions Calvert was a
Township of the young with more than
half of the 350 settlers there under the
age of 20 there was an overabundance of
children many of whom had probably never
seen someone of African descent so this
was not just about education this was
about intimacy culverts schools each
consisted of one room with one teacher
who oversaw the education all the
children in the school district the
system required the children of
different ages and skills
teach each other sitting side-by-side on
benches leaning over each other's slates
to work on sums holding a book between
them as they read aloud an integrated
school meant that a black child who was
an excellent reader could be well be
placed with an older white student to
help them labor through their McGuffey
readers the white families of covert
knew all this and the school board knew
that allowing the Connor Tyler and Seton
children to attend the local school on
William bright Connors land would be
breaking the law
Adolphus Sherbourne a member
the school superintendent board was only
in his early 20s and it come from Canada
with his extended family he and his
family had been farming in the area for
a few years by 1866 he was uncle to
school-aged children and as a single man
had the time to be involved in local
politics the group from Cass County had
settled in the school district he
oversaw so it made sense that he go to
their home to speak with them he brought
with him a sturdy piece of paper issued
by the state government because he was
visiting on official business the piece
of paper that he brought with him that
day was a school record issued by the
state as overseer a school district for
the state required that Adolphus
Sherbourne to count count every person
in the district between five and 20
years of age and he intended to do just
that when he came to the Connor
homestead an interesting conversation
must have taken place having their
children recorded with their race
labeled would have brought the state
down on Elizabeth William Heinrich and
the other parents who were determined
that their children should be treated as
equal citizens but they that did not
seem to be sherburn's aim we don't know
how the decision was made but a course
of action had been agreed on by the
all-white all-male school board a
decision that Sherbourne was to make
clear to these newcomers their children
were accepted and invited by the board
to go to school and the board would
attempt to do everything in its power to
protect their children from the scrutiny
and judgment of the state government
Adolphus Sherbourne must have stood in
the doorway of the Conner cabin and told
them all of this and then taken down the
names the children who were at home
there was Little John Connor aged five
the only school-aged child of William
Frank and Elizabeth Shepard Connor then
there were the children of William
Frank's father William bright Connor who
was now widowed and remarried to Abigail
Cordelia at 12 years old was the
youngest of William brights children
from his first marriage and she now had
a six-year-old half-brother called
Alexander finally they were all three of
Heinrich Tyler's motherless sons
Octavius age
Cornelius aged seven and jimmy aged five
together these children made almost a
third of the school-age population in
district 4
what must those parents of thought as
they watched Adolphus walk away they may
have stood outside their cabin watching
knowing their children's names were
neatly written on the folded piece of
paper he carried with him watching his
pale form moving through the clothes
trees until it disappeared into the
unceasing green what a risk they were
all taking that day courage trust and
faith had to be held together hard by
both sides while the group of
african-americans from Cass County was
focusing on having their children
integrate into covert schools the pom
peas were going after an even bigger
prize political power but first they had
to hack out a homestead the Pompey
brothers had bought good land between
Heinrichs and that of the white Levi's
friend Levi was much like them young
single and eager to succeed famous in
the township for the outrageous act of
buying a piece of precious plate glass
to create a window he could see through
the first of its kind in covert before
that you just put leather over any hole
you might have in your house and even
after that he was the first before young
men three black one white saw a great
deal of one another as they struggled
together to survive is Heinrich later
put it and I quote we live near each
other came into a new country and worked
much together aiding each other the pomp
ease intention for one of their family
members to gain a political position was
a bold one this was a time when even
well-known and respected African
Americans could not ride molested on a
train out east just a few months earlier
Harriet Tubman who had survived so much
before the war was riding a train in New
Jersey when she was dragged by a
conductor and his three aides from her
first-class seat and thrown with such
force into the baggage car that she was
injured if White's would do this to a
famous black woman one can only imagine
what retribution could be wreaked on an
unknown black man
demanding not just equality but power
that man would be Dawson Pompey
Washington and Napoleon's father once
they disorder that they had found a good
community where Dawson could make a good
home he moved from Whitley County
Indiana leaving behind his brother
fielding with whom he had survived
untold trials to become the free landed
farmer that he was Dawson's farm in
Indiana must have been a valuable one
for he was able to buy what was widely
considered the best piece of farmland in
covert 160 acre homestead near the
village that was one of the only cleared
pieces of land in the frontier community
to create cleared land was no mean feat
in heavily timbered covert for many
years the air was thick with a smoke of
the burning trees that settlers
desperate for open fields satellite
where they had felt them when the earth
could finally be broken under the plow
he was black from the ashes the forest
that had once grown close around the
farmsteads by 1870 Dawson's land was
worth $6,000 to put this amount into
context a few years earlier in 1863 when
the conscription act was passed to draft
men into the Union Army a man who did
not wish to fight would have to pay a
$300 bond a life-saving amount too large
for many to afford in 1860 a male farm
laborer in Michigan could expect a wage
of around just 50 cents a day and the
average yearly earnings of a wage
laborer in 1870 were 186 dollars a year
by 1868 Dawson and his extended family
were well settled in their new home
being on some of the best land in the
township Dawson was almost certainly
taxed accordingly and he had sons who
had proven their title to citizenship by
fighting for their nation
so Dawson decided to attend the local
Township election his aim was not only
to vote in a legal action in itself but
to win a position in the township
government this was beyond illegal it
was audacious particularly given the
state of things in Michigan in 1866 a
man by the name of William Dean from
Eastern Michigan and
would become a suburb of Detroit had
attempted to vote in his Township
selection to most dean looked white but
someone in his community knew that one
of his ancestors generations ago had
come from Africa and he was arrested and
sentenced for the crime of voting while
1/16 black in 1867 just one year after
William Dean had been imprisoned for
trying to vote white Michigan voters
turned out in vast numbers to vote
against allowing black men to become
full citizens still dawson papi would
not be dissuaded the position that he
wanted was a significant one the
position of highway overseer in his
district and he must have known that a
white man already desired it if he won
his duties would include gathering taxes
from roughly 30 taxpaying members of the
district as well as managing roadwork
that labor was supplied by the men of
each district who required either to pay
tax or give a certain amount of time to
building the roads since most frontier
homesteads were cash-poor
the bulk of dawson Papi's work for the
township would be overseeing a team of
white men doing the heavy labor of
chopping down trees cutting brush and
leveling earth by hand although the
Civil War had supposedly won freedom and
rights for all black Americans in a
strange twist people of African descent
were grant granted the right to vote in
the former Confederate States by a
federal government that could force the
issue whereas in many of the Union
states Michigan being one of them civil
rights had not been granted however just
because blacks in the South had the
legal right to vote did not mean they
had the real freedom to do so man who
tried to vote found their homes and
crops burned or worse their persons and
families attacked by murderous mobs it
is estimated that between a short period
of 1868 and 1871 at least 400 people of
African descent were lynched in the
south because like Dawson they were free
and dared to think of themselves as
citizens now Dawson was daring to do
just that in covert politics was one of
the rare things that brought the
residents the
Township together this is no metaphor
there were a few reasons for the people
of covert to gather outside of these
Township elections and realistically no
easy places for them to do so even if
they wanted to there was no church
founded and no Town Hall built and the
schools gathered only the children from
each district it was one of those
schools that hosted the elections that
April there is no record of how the
votes were counted only that the
elections moved swiftly which makes it
likely that there was no secret ballot
only voiced intentions and a show of
hands Dawson and his family must have
been mightily keyed up by the time it
was their turn the vote for the highway
overseers was announced the elections
were held in order of districts with
James Tripp and Draper fish winning
their positions in districts one and two
then came the surprise
Joseph toke won a local Pokagon stepped
forward for the position in the district
where he lived most of those gathered
there that day would have been aware
that as a quote Indian as he was later
described in the voting records he had
no right to vote much less hold office
but then again they all knew that the
Vulcans were the primary residents of
district 3 so it must have seemed only
fair that he be allowed to oversee the
work of his kin in creating roads in
that region and he was voted into the
position
only white men stepped in to fill the
remaining positions until it came to the
last one district 7
this was the very district the elections
were being held in and it had one of the
largest budgets as well as the best
equipment for the township had just
bought a scraper for the roads already
built in this district now Dawson took
his courage in his hands and stepped you
for the men we hoped continued to be his
neighbors here he was a relatively
wealthy black man who when he had
arrived in covert bought the only piece
of cleared land in the township a fact
that must have still rankled some of the
white homesteaders who were trying to
eke out a living from the few bare
patches of land that they were able to
clear and now he was attempting to break
laws and social conventions by running
for the position of highway overseer of
his district a powerful post previous
we held by some of the most prestigious
white men in the township nevertheless
that day in April 1868 the men must have
looked at Dawson and met his gaze
raising their hands and calling out
their votes as the township clerk
scrawled across the ledger page highway
district 7
Dawson Pompey they had done it this
motley crew of struggling pioneers from
New York Massachusetts England and
Germany and the proud men of African
descent who had made their way from the
south and other parts of the Midwest
were willing to do what so few were able
to even consider vote for a black man
instead of a white man breaking the
boundaries of race and the law thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
now we have time for questions and I'm
more than happy to answer them I also
want to add that afterwards I will be
signing books in the back there are some
for sale and you have longer and more
involved in questions please do come and
talk to me out there afterwards
questions yes there in front let's give
them a minute to get the mic there okay
yes I'm from the town of covert I work
here in Holland thank you for coming and
are you going to be doing any sort of
extensions of your book as far as what
the town is doing as of today and I
hadn't planned on it it's one of the the
problems of being a 19th century
historian but it is fascinating to see
how coverts culture of equality has
continued to survive throughout the 20th
century and I'm really grateful that
you're here today
thanks for coming yes you have a
question
I just want to thank you from the bottom
of my heart for this beautiful piece of
history regarding our hometown culture
and god bless you and thank you thank
you
[Applause]
it was twelve years of work and I'm glad
you think it was worth it ah yes in the
back you just wait a minute he's gonna
come your way chat so any research into
the white families and the white
individuals who came there as to what
may have predisposed them to being so
open to integrating hmm I was able to do
some research on the families that of
both races that arrived as to what
exactly predisposed them there are many
answers really complicated ones I wish
that there was one big simple answer for
covert but it's actually much more
complicated it wasn't an issue of just
sort of one big powerful person or law
saying this is how you should live it
was a much more personal thing and it
seemed to be made a lot of these were
smaller decisions that were made and a
sort of a personal daily basis by people
it's one of the things that I found so
gripping about covert is that it was
such a sort of an intimate story of race
relations I think that there was one of
the families that had a lot of influence
one of the white families that had a lot
of influence was the Packard family they
arrived in about 1869 1870 little after
the Township was integrated and they had
a history of radical abolitionist
tendencies and they set up the big
logging mills in the township that
started the logging boom that saw the
township population tripling and for
that particular period of time they
seemed to have been quite influential in
that they seemed to be living out their
ideals of the sort of gara Sounion type
of abolitionism that believed in
integration and inequality so they
actively hired African Americans into
their Mills when they started to church
they actively recruited black membership
and when they when African Americans
arrived in the township needing
financial help a lot of people who
arrived needed a little bit of startup
money in order to start a business
the Packard's were more than willing to
offer loans at the same rates they
offered to whites to help
african-americans start up farms or
businesses than Township by
that said of course they arrived after
the Township was initially integrated
and I think it had a lot to do initially
with the fact their civil war veterans
from the Union side both whites and
blacks who were there at that time also
the African Americans that arrived it
took a lot of grace and courage for them
to come from these all-black communities
that they came from the Midwest and
settle and covert and I think they were
very politicized by their experience in
the civil war they saw a lot of action
there's actually a chapter in here that
talks a lot about the battles that they
were involved in and I can't read that I
was breakups they're crying because the
battle but so I had a lot to do with
them and the fact that they were
constantly pushing throughout the 19th
century for more equality and and even
more recognition for the fact that they
were a unique people and covert and and
the best thing I could tell you is
probably read the book and see all the
complicated reasons why this happened
it's the best answer I could give you I
also want to thank you for all your
research and everything as I was raised
my great grandparents are also from
covert wonderful and when your book came
out in fact I got two copies that I have
been loaning to people because I told
them Isis if you really want to know why
I'm colorblind
you need to read this book this is how I
was raised and yes what you just said is
actually correct it was as I was raised
it was just we were just community mm
even in the 20th century that's good to
know that's good to know thank you thank
you
hmm
yes I too want to thank you for the book
marvelous book and I was going to ask
you about what I call intentionality but
I think the question you've just been
answering before deals with that partly
but maybe we can come around to it in
this way and that is the African
Americans who came to covert do you have
any idea of how they found out about
covert in the first place I mean for
example are very often in the 19th
century there were land agents who
circulated
advertising but come here because and
I'm wondering if maybe some of that
advertising perhaps talked about freedom
or in some way led people to think that
hmm good question
I think it had more to do with economics
probably because I haven't found any
record of that kind of thing going on
but the land was extremely inexpensive
Van Buren County was actually the last
County to be settled in the lower
portion of the state of Michigan so this
was land owned by the federal government
obviously they kicked most of the Native
Americans out quite violently so this
was open land it wasn't particularly
great land a lot of land was rather
sandy a rather poor soil on kind of
swampy but it was land that was
available to young people whether black
or white who might be able to afford
paying the small amount from the
government and start new lives there so
in that way these African Americans were
traditional pioneers they were searching
for a better life in an area where they
could actually afford to move to and
start a home and I think that they made
they helped make that culture happen
once they arrived that it wasn't might
not have just been they're already
waiting for them
III really want to stress that the
interesting thing for me about covert
that it wasn't just a matter of whites
in the area being paternalistic I'm sort
of patting african-americans on the head
and saying oh you can do this it's okay
it was much more
this melding of African Americans really
courageously asserting their their
rights even if those rights were illegal
at the time to be treated as equals to
be integrated and then whites welcoming
those assertions and and welcoming those
those pushes to do that and together
creating this community it was not a
utopian community that's the other thing
that had tricked me about it you have
communities like Oberlin Ohio which were
integrated those were started before the
civil wars deliberately utopian
communities that were based on this
abolitionist model and whereas in in
covert it really did get started as a
much more I dare I say normal frontier
community with people just sort of
slowly arriving now obviously once that
culture of equality got started then
whites who came to that area had to
decide whether they were willing to
tolerate that or not and there's
actually some cases in which that I
found in my book in which it was obvious
that some whites weren't and neither
challenged it or or left but then once
it got started it would have really
taken an act of violence to change it
and and so in that way by about the
1870s or 1880s what covert was doing was
very conservative albeit very radical
but it was conservative and that a lot
of America was turning its back on the
ideals of integration in equality where
as this this interesting group of Civil
War veterans and Congregationalists and
and farmers decided they would continue
on this path that a lot of America was
turning turning back on you mentioned
that the area had a lot of young people
what was their experience with
interracial dating and interracial
marriage was that a fact of life for
them excellent question thank you it was
there was some in the 19th century I
found at least there about two couples
in the sort of until about the 1890s now
the 1890s saw a sharp rise in violence
across the rural Midwest in a lot of
rural communities who are whites were
turning on their black neighbors
oftentimes burning down their home
driving them out of their communities
and multiracial families were
particularly focuses of this type of
violence so in the 1890s covert actually
saw a very large influx of interracial
married couples and families into the
community I think they were almost
fleeing there as a South as a safe haven
so you have I think in the 1890s there
about six of them and some of them are
really really wonderful so my favorite
there at least two that were like this
you had an african-american woman and a
white man and they were both widowed so
they each came to the marriage with
children from their previous marriages
and then they had children of their own
and and that happened there was more
than one couple who was like that in
covert yeah yes in the middle there I
really appreciated the intimacy of your
narrative I think the way you attempted
to enter in imaginative ly into the
lives of these characters and I'd like
to know more about your sources to what
extent were you able to use personal
documents letters diaries or even oral
tradition thank you um a lot but that
took a lot of time that's that's why it
this book took me so many years to write
I I sometimes would stop in the middle
of writing and just I wish I was a
novelist because I could just make this
stuff up every single time I wanted to
talk about somebody's child or
somebody's eye color I had to go to
military documents or census records and
and 19th century handwriting isn't
always the easiest thing to read but it
was important to me to stick to
absolutely to the facts and and to the
documents while I posit what may have
occurred I never actually make anything
up and that's really important to me
because what happened in covert was so
unusual that I really needed to let this
document speak for themselves
there were Diaries that were loaned to
me letters and the oral histories were
particularly I'm particularly grateful
for some of the descendants of these
pioneer families in covert after knowing
for me for some years did
open up with these amazing stories that
they preserved within their families for
generations and and sometimes it's the
only ways to to get these important
stories so I'm incredibly grateful to
them for that and and that also took
time because it's it's important for
people to get to know each other before
trusting each other and I was very
grateful for that trust how did you
become an historian and in the second
part I'm really interested how might
that calling have drawn you to this
particular topic mm-hmm I think that I
think I got interested in history
through through many ways but I was
always interested in in the sort of
personal the personal stories of the
past political history obviously is very
important I can get as excited as
anybody about civil war but for me I was
very intrigued in and what people's
lives were like in the past and how in
some ways it feels like the past is
almost a different country that a
country that I wanted to visit so I
think that's how I initially got engaged
with it and then this story in
particular drew me and I think because
of something that's also in my family
background of a real interest in issues
about racism in America my mother was
involved in the civil rights movement
and it was really intriguing for me to
discover community that was so
completely integrated that had equality
across the board and to look at how they
made that work on so many levels it was
less a question for me of a why than how
and and and so I think that's that's
another reason why it took me so long as
I just sort of wanted to find out many
of those answers and it was also
important for me to understand how this
minority group within this majority
group was able to assert difference even
though they were completely integrated
in her and I was really interested in
the ways that the African Americans
we're able to do that they started a
emancipation festival in the late 1870s
which the entire town celebrated and
they actually celebrated that in various
other communities outside of covert they
started an all-black Masonic Lodge and
basically we're creating and asserting
their own unique and proud heritage in
the same way that the Irish might during
them st. Patrick's Day or something like
that and and in a way that was very
warmly welcomed by the community at
large and that was really intriguing to
me so obviously I could go on for a long
time talking about this community but it
really it captured my heart in the 19th
century most of the 19th century African
it was the population the overall
population of covert was about 1400 I
mean it started off at about 350 it grew
to about a thousand in the 1870s and
then it capped out at about 1200 1400
african-americans were about 9% of the
population now they mean that may not
seem terribly a large number but there's
two very interesting things about that
statistic first they were physically
integrated across the township they
didn't just live in one section of the
township
they lived scattered across the township
they also held an a disproportionate
number of positions of power so there
was always one if not three or four
african-americans in elected positions
throughout the 19th century in covert
which far outweighed their actual
numbers they also had a lot of power
positions within the Grange Society
within the Grand Army of the Republic
which was the Union Civil War veterans
Association so they were very very
visible and I found something very
interesting great disheartening they're
very interesting about race relations in
the 19th century Midwest that that
Midwest had an odd form of racism that
wasn't really based on numbers
particularly the rural Midwest m''d have
whole townships that were variant ly
racist toward the one
scent of african-americans that were
living there or you had whole townships
in in 1867 voting against what black
suffrage who had no black neighbors at
all I mean this wasn't any skin off
their nose to vote for this but still
they didn't want to they were still they
were still very racist despite the fact
that they didn't have any black
neighbors and and there is an argument
that some statistical story ins have
made that particularly those who study
urban areas that there's this magic 10%
number that once it gets passed 10
percent all the white folks that have
look at theirs who watches and say oh
we've gotten past ten percent we'd
better start rioting and I think that it
racism isn't quite that rational racism
is completely irrational and it's also a
choice that people make and in that way
covert is a rather bittersweet story
it's a story of hope but it's also very
bittersweet because it makes clear that
these people were in culvert we're
making choices not to be racist which
means that many other communities across
the Midway West were making choices to
be racist which is a real heart breaker
supposed to be the way they were and
accepting of the black mm-hmm which is
sort of the big question of why why did
it happen right it's a question I often
get asked and I'm very leery of giving
one simple answer because I don't
believe there is one first and and
second I guess I would ask I asked back
and I mentioned this in the book why not
I think that we have as a nation maybe
come to the point where we believe that
racism may be just sort of happens it's
where our nation will slide if given
half a chance it's just sort of in the
air or in the water but covert so really
does raise the question of why not and
and I think that that's what I was
hoping to raise when writing the book I
wanted people to sort of look at the
complicated ways that people and end
intimate and
always the people were crossing those
racial boundaries that were so rarely
crossed in the 19th century and how that
in the end had a larger ripple effect
create an entire community for me the
story of covert is much more about the
power that individuals have to make a
difference to create a community but
then I have to add that there's also
something about the mystery of goodness
a lot of philosophers deal a lot with
why evil occurs and that's a very
important question to ask but I think
one of the questions that covert raises
is why does good occur and that's oh
really I mean better minds than I have
have attempted to grapple with that one
and I have tried to give many small and
sort of complicated answers but I hope
that they are in some ways heartening to
people who read them any other questions
yes in the back of the back corner there
I'll just give just a word my question I
guess ruins and I do appreciate you
coming a friend of mine read about you
and I think quite a few friends at
living Cobra hmm ever I live in
Fayetteville okay so be interesting
cover why did you choose Cobra weather
than Schoolcraft for the Underground
Railroad
Battle Creek what made you decide I'm
over ah why did I decide on covert I
originally to be fair I originally
thought that my project that I started
as a senior in college was going to be
about the Underground Railroad I wanted
to do local history and one of my I
should give credit where credit is due
my my mother actually was the one who
helped me find covert I was telling I
was looking for a community that I could
study about race relations during the
Civil War and one of my mother's
colleagues was African American and
she'd grown up in covert and she said
you know Cobra it's a very interesting
community I think it was on the
Underground Railroad and your daughter
should investigate it so called the
local public librarian got the local
public librarian and she said you need
to talk to Pearl Sarno she is our
community's historian and she knows
everything there is to know about covert
so at that time Cobra pearl was in her
70s I got her on the phone and I said
I'm gonna do this paper about Cobra and
it's gonna be about the Underground
Railroad and aren't you excited there's
a long pause on the other end of the
phone she said Randy defensively well we
weren't on the Underground Railroad but
we've been integrated for a very long
time and I think that's just as
interesting I was a little disappointed
at first but I began to think about it
and at that time there's a lot of
studies coming out that said that they
were showing that some of the
abolitionists that were involved in the
Underground Railroad weren't
particularly warm towards the idea of
black neighbors they didn't mind hiding
somebody in their basement and then
sending them to Canada but they weren't
so interested in having maybe black
settlers around them now we've
discovered that things are much more
complicated than that and there actually
was real danger especially after 1850
and this Fugitive Slave Act was passed
of slave Raiders coming up even as far
north as Michigan and just grabbing
people they found so there were some
cases in which it was safer to go to
Canada but I started reading these
documents that Pearl Sarno had saved
many of them in her basement that were
the voting records in the school census
records in fact I still remember opening
up this hefty piece of blue paper that's
the one I talked about adolphus sure
burn bringing to the Conner household
and reading those names that had no race
mentioned all next to those names I had
to go to the census record to find out
what the races those children were and I
remember just starting to weep because I
realized what was starting to happen in
this community and then I was hooked I
was [ __ ]
there's no way I could go back yeah you
have had your hand up for a while here
in the green shirt way in the back hi I
myself am enjoying professor Johnson's
495 to history seminar and I did I dealt
with the primary documents with with one
individual and I was wondering how you
start to know the person and you get so
inside them when when you're researching
grantor or any other president or
someone else there they're a little more
aloof it's not it's not the same it's
just some average person and how you
felt doing with with individuals and
then now that it's over or you say it
and
hmm so the question is how how did I
sort of how engage did I get in people's
lives as an historian and in the people
that I was studying and and am i sad
that the study is now over
I definitely got engaged in their lies I
sometimes felt like I knew people in
covert better than I knew some members
of my own family I was so immersed in
their lives and and I really grow to
care for them and it really broke my
heart when I discovered when they died
and and or when one of their children
died and I really I said if I felt like
I was kind of living in covert for a
while there at the same time I'm rather
I'm very glad to see the book done I'm
very glad to have it out there but at
the same time and now that the book is
out I have people who come up to me and
say oh I grew up in covert I have these
wonderful old photographs and oh it just
kills me and I wish of course I'm
tempted but I'm hoping that this study
will raise interest in this area and in
race relations in the in the rural
nineteenth-century Midwest and that
other people will start following me and
in studying this area and I'm a covert
will always be a part of me and I think
I will I feel a little bit like the Tate
family in Chicago who are descendants of
the pom peas in the Tyler family and
Ernestine Carter Tate was one of the
people that I interviewed a great deal
was incredibly helpful to me there are a
number of her photographs from her
personal collection and remember her
telling me that this was only about ten
years ago
when her mother died her mother had come
from covert to Chicago in the 1910s late
1910s when her mother died they had a
funeral procession all the way from
Chicago to covert because that was home
that was where she wanted to be buried
that's where people are buried there and
there's this incredible tie to that
community that people who grew up there
and now scattered feel and and I
definitely feel that same kind of tie
there and sort of a a Hart home for me
yeah way in the back thank you again for
uncovering covert which I also have a
heart my heart there and we used buy
fruit at the cirno farm stand so um as a
social anthropologist and I live in a
community that is now slowly integrating
and much to my son's dismay is extremely
slow at any form of integration what can
we learn from your book and how can
either the academic community or the
government community or school
communities take what you learned and
and grow from it
ah that's that's a harder question for
me obviously we don't live in a mainly
agrarian society anymore
but we still have frontiers I believe
that we still have frontiers we still
have you know new developments that
start up from scratch people move to new
communities that are getting to sort of
built up in the middle of nowhere it's
very much a part of our culture today
and boy I don't have any simple
prescription my friend James Horton
who's a wonderful historian of
african-american history said to me one
time after I gave a presentation on this
at a major conference in st. Louis he
came up to me afterward and he said I
want you to bottle it and sell it I wish
I could but I think that what I'm hoping
is that people will read the book and
find some examples that sound might
sound possible to them just just really
small examples about creating
friendships getting to know people as
human beings whether white or black and
obviously the fact that I wrote this
book and I am aware of this doesn't
affect anybody who lived in covert in
the 19th century I mean they live their
lives they lived extraordinary lives and
you know that that did this doesn't
change it the only thing that history
changes is the present and I did write
this book very deliberately hoping that
there would people would come to it and
and gain some hope and some insight
into our nation's past it's a very
unusual little tiny portion of our
nation's past obviously the only reason
that covert is even interesting is
because things were so terrible in most
of the 19th century Midwest but I'm
really hoping that we can take we need
the past to remind us of course not only
of the evils that were done so that we
do not replicate them but the good
things that occurred so that maybe we
can try to follow in that path and
realize that that's part of our heritage
as a nation as well yeah I'm gonna try
to see if it's anybody else
yes so the book answers this question
you seem to be talking a lot about
personal relationships and the lack of
personal discrimination that's going on
and that it did reach some of the
institutional level of the example
african-american elective is a wonderful
example in that there was high rent
going on how much at the institutional
level in that time period was there that
equality where a lot of people being
hired for the same kind of work was paid
equal in covert or across the Midwest
well in covert ok I don't know much
about the communities my question might
even sound ignorant but no no no I do
teach the difference between personal
discrimination and institutionalization
and there is an overlap because we as
individuals make up our institutions
course and so that's important but I'm
curious what you uncovered at the
institutional level it was actually
easier for me to uncover the
institutional level because of the
records than it was the personal level
although may not look like that in the
book because I include a lot of these
personal stories but at the
institutional level it was really the
integration was really extraordinary the
the Grand Army of the Republic which was
an extremely empower 'fl organization in
the United States in the late 19th
century which was the Union Civil War
veterans organization in culvert was
completely integrated throughout the
19th and early 20th century until the
veterans died in fact African Americans
held some of the highest positions
within that post the grange lodge was
completely integrated obviously that
that sort of lodge of power politics was
also completely integrated the church
was also integrated and that's very
interesting to me there was one church
in covert most of the 19th century it
was a Congregational Church and the
history of church integration in the
midwest is not a particularly pretty one
even churches in ohio in the 19th
century that would welcome
african-american membership
african-americans still had to live and
if we sit in a particular area of the
church where as in culvert it is it's
absolutely obvious that they were
sitting next to side-by-side with whites
and in fact they were black deacons in
the church and people instead of power
positions within the church I was very
interested that in the 1890s the church
started a Bible study program which met
in people's homes and there was about 12
of these clubs that got started and many
of them
were integrated in fact some of them
were up to half african-american and and
those would meet they would meet in each
other's homes so it wasn't just meeting
in the church it was meeting in this
sort of intimate and personal spaces so
in that way the institution actually
helped lead to further integration as
more people came in to covert joined the
church and and did this I will point out
I do not believe that the people of Cove
were colorblind I think that initially
in particular they had a heightened
awareness of race and and a heightened
awareness of identity in order to do
what they did that it was very important
for the African Americans to assert
their own identity and to say we do we
have a unique heritage as black
Americans and I think that that was
something that was celebrated so in
other words race was recognized in
covert but it was not recognized as a
reason to denigrate but as a reason to
celebrate and that's a big difference
question here thank you very much for a
splendid presentation I'm looking
forward to reading the book I have a
couple of questions they're related how
long did it take
or first question is how many of the
african-american students who enrolled
in that school completed their education
through the eighth grade there and
secondly how long did it take before
there were african-american teachers in
that school or any school in the
township the question is about the
african-american students it's very hard
to tell from the records because
unfortunately the school census records
many of them were destroyed so I've got
a kind of spotty spotty records of of
attendance but what I do know is that
literacy rates are extremely high in the
township by 1870 they were at 97% for
both african-americans and whites and
and the books that they were reading
room that were in the school library
were really astonishing many of them
were radically abolitionist texts and
novels like Harriet Beecher Stowe's
bread which was had as its
main character person based overtly on
that Turner the slave rebel leader so
you had that going on I came across a
really moving example in about 1872 of
an african-american family that moved
into kovat from Indiana where integrated
education or education for African
Americans at all was very difficult to
attain to the youngest children in this
family started attending they came with
her father there the father was a
widower and they were school-age I mean
they were sort of eight and twelve but
then their elder brother started
attending with them he was 21 years old
but he was obvious that this was his
first opportunity to attend school and
learn to read their father wasn't
literate and so he sat there with his
all these children to learn to read so
this was something that was really core
in the heart of this community as two
African American teachers their covert
was very traditional in this way most
teachers were young unmarried women and
all of them were white I found no
records of African Americans attempting
to even be teachers however William
Frank Conner who was elected to the
position of Justice of the Peace in
covert in 1875 the first black man in
Michigan to be elected to such a
powerful position ended up being on the
school board for most of the later half
of the 19th century so he was a black
man overseeing the work of white
teachers so African Americans were
absolutely involved in in the
educational process in covert yeah but
you said about the school teachers
babying wonder if you noticed evidence
of progressive attitudes on other fronts
even if it wasn't the story that you
were looking for for example did you
notice progressive attitudes towards
women's rights issues another kind of
hot
button topics certainly during the time
and recognizing that that wasn't the
story that you were after did you see
overlap there
I didn't as a whole III hate to say that
this but in many ways cover was a very
normal Midwestern nineteenth-century
community its gender relations were very
I mean they were farming families so
women took a very large part in the
economic life of the family as many
women farming women did but they there
weren't any women voting and so in that
way it was it was quite traditional but
yet radical where the race relations was
concerned they were big on prohibition
the Packers were in particular and I
think for a while it was a dry Township
which actually probably that happened
during the logging boom and I think that
helped the violence levels the loggers
who came into the township were
notoriously violent rowdy bunch in fact
there's an incredible example I read one
time reminiscence by a young man who was
a child around the turn of the century
and he remembered sitting on his uncle's
lap we'd been a logger in covert in the
1870s and he was missing the tops of his
ears in the bottom of his ears they've
been bitten off during fights in the
logging camps so life was pretty violent
and it could have been that the
prohibition of alcohol was just sort of
for self-protection during that very
difficult period but in that in many
ways it was sort of a very traditional
church-going Protestant work ethic kind
of community with these incredibly
radical race relations no thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]